it's chocolate
oh
i haven't had sex in over 13 years i'm
going to do a lot of making up for that
let's see how it tastes
debbie is getting her groove back y'all
i'm all had fun i have a good time i
know how to
go out and have fun i still do clearly
in our first look at season 3 of 90 day
fiance the single life things get spicy
for debbie who we all know better as
cole johnson's mom who was first
introduced to us on 90 day fiance season
six i'm putting myself out there she's
trying right now putting herself out
there the 69 year old continues her
quest to find love even if the dating
game hasn't been so kind to her in the
past it would be nice to celebrate my
70s with someone close to my heart i'm
good in bed
okay turn up debbie on season two of the
single life we saw deb get a makeover as
she dove back into the dating pool she
changed her hairstyle and color got a
new tattoo oh and some botox for good
measure this is one of the greatest
makeovers
yeah i'm really excited
after her transformation debbie learned
that just because you judge up your
looks doesn't mean life will be any
different for you
she met a guy named jay and on their
second date he ghosted her where are you
where was the date
thank you very much
on top of that debbie googled him and
found out he's a married man
married but it's nice to see that bummer
of a moment didn't discourage deb from
her quest to find true love and from the
looks of this trailer she might finally
get lucky
it's chocolate
oh
i haven't had sex in over 13 years i'm
going to do a lot of making up for the
best let's see how it tastes
in a while debbie's busy getting her
groove on she'll also have to deal with
the main man in her life colt i'm upset
that you just can't do anything by
yourself on last season's tell-all colt
didn't hold back his frustration about
his mom and how much she relies on him i
need you you're my son
i do care you don't care about me
tony i want to be with you so much
now cold and debbie aren't the only two
we'll be tuning in for on the new season
because natalie's back and reuniting
with mike
last time we saw these two together was
during the last talal in february it
might push natalie to finally make their
divorce official at the time natalie
didn't have a green card which meant a
divorce would send her home to ukraine
it's time it's time but based on the new
trailer it seems like natalie worked
something out she's still in the u.s and
apparently dating a new man there's this
hot guy next to me i feel like i'm in
hollywood
and i love it
yeah that looks like it fizzles though
because the trailer gives us this moment
too
go
for me sexy serious
uses me and it ends with her at mike's
door
i hope i can decide with whom i want to
spend rest of my life
[Music]
interesting
season 3 of 90 day fiance the single
life also stars franchise alums tiffany
tanya caesar and tim's ex and pillow
talk favorite veronica this season
premieres monday september 12th on tlc
and discovery plus
[Music]